would you buy
we don't the show let's go eat it's a
beautiful day here in Toronto and city
on a Saturday and one of my favorite
things to do when it's nice outside is
hop on the Vespa go downtown and have a
few fun surprises or my wife Nina so
here we go can we made it who's got
worse helmet head yeah really yeah I
don't have time I can't even have lines
look at that let's go eat here we are la
pizzeria so this pizza is supposed to be
ready in three
three minutes that's a creation that
that the entrepreneur owner of this
place came up with soap it's in three
minutes and see how it goes and here it
is fastest pizza ever half canadian or
no oh canada with potato chips bacon and
cheese and half mushrooms with sauteed
mushroom the brown mushrooms mozzarella
cheese yum yum yum
so as much as I love routine and having
set day to set things i also like
shaking things up is it be a boy doing
the same thing over and over over over
again and i go your mind to new things
so here we go we got we got pizza i saw
a guy who the window it's a nice window
here where you got a lot of people
traffic oh my god wat by than i thought
i knew right like those people you think
you recognize and I kind of waved at him
he came in and he said hi and it's one
of those cause even though I don't
remember where we sprout remember his
name but he looks familiar and when he
came in and I said hey this is my wife
Nina I didn't say his name for her so I
don't remember now it's killing me is
killing you who is this guy I gotta
remember anyway we'll see where it's
going to come to me I think at some
point okay memory it was like oh there's
nobody in here which is very skeptical I
found this place online all right how do
you feel that
thumbs up the first of many surprises
for the day all right next up voted one
of the best ice cream stores in Toronto
Ed's real scoop Nina on some ice cream
sucky thing about filming with an iPad
is the defaults to picture mode each
time time I load it up I'll switch the
video anyway we got our ice cream I got
creme brulee and burnt marshmallow Nina
just did you get I got more
okay let's have a taste here next up is
the Toronto Tool Library Nina is excited
so Toronto recently launched this tulus
library i will usually get tools rent
tools and use them for your house and
return them so we're going to check it
out and see if there's any surprises for
us there's also the promo seeds library
which is this you can get seats to find
if you just take yeah you're the first
thing I get in there so what did you get
so we're like they suck a bag of
zucchini see two cucumbers you buy
whatever 31 sunflower well I choose my
work for my colleague she really likes
sunflowers so I'm gonna give this one
finger cilantro Evan justhello cilantro
so I'm just gonna try it lunch was good
look so much and I've never had a large
black a little black tomatoes so I'm
gonna try this one and see what happens
two bags of cherry tomato
two bags of Brandywine tomatoes you've
got a lot of gardening to do this is a
cool program called the Toronto Seed
Library and it's all community runs and
we're going to look at setting one up at
Toronto dance salsa and bringing a
little bit north and when we have events
having some seeds to be able to give
away so I'm going to be in touch and
maybe we'll make a video about trying to
seed libraries you look good yeah so
it's Dutch day at City Hall and we're
here taking some festivities with
everything Dutch
and that's from World War two the
Canadians were the ones who have
liberate the Dutch from the Nazis and so
there's a strong loyalty from the Dutch
towards Canada that still lasted today
to this whole festival is to thank
Canada and showcase some Dutch pride
another reason i love Toronto designated
motorcycle and scooter parking so we're
now outside eden center which is one of
the biggest malls in Canada anymore
what's a call
so we're standing outside the eaton
centre right now canon wanna come as
biggest malls because we're looking for
is some new clothes for Nina excited
okay here we go Nina what does the sign
say okay so this is toronto eaton center
still laughter dog howl of escalators
okay we went to our first store you know
her first purchase what do we got
you don't the show mean about underwear
you know what panties 10 10 panties from
lessons is very excited it's lavender
panties hate stores where I have to
stand and they don't have any work for
guys to sit
my name is out
okay oh yeah that's a bag this is the
front this is the dress no I don't like
the color the jeans that I think don't
you lose like lights okay well that was
a fun time let's keep going
alright it's early dinner time you know
would you get
I got aim w teen burger combo yeah NEMA
still hasn't bought anything new we find
the Stars it's a little depressing so
we're going to have some really dinner
and then keep our shopping experience
going yeah
so it's YouTube FanFest day here in
Toronto crowds are kind of crazy
that is the best part of Chairman yeah
and somebody's gonna be on stage I don't
know who's gonna be up there there's
Nina Nina's a YouTube star nina plant
stuff and try stuff on and shows us all
these fun cool things and we learned
today that she's half dutch we're gonna
go back we're gonna go look for one shot
me we're shopping are you then I don't
know more shopping more shopping here we
go ok so we're heading home Nina didn't
buy anything else very sad just the
panties but just got 10 pairs of new
paintings which is very exciting for you
excited for you exciting for me exciting
for you probably not anybody else
all right back on the Vespa and home we
go Thank You Toronto we're home we're
tired we're taking a nap